welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farron cousins from ring of fire
let's get back into some of the news of
the week and
one of the more interesting
non-january six things that have
happened this week
is that marjorie taylor greene
has been suffering basically a week-long
meltdown
for so very many different reasons
the first of course is the fact that it
was recently revealed that the
individual that has been
defacing her uh transphobic sign outside
of her office turns out to be the chief
of staff to a democratic representative
and the capitol police were able to find
this individual they put up you know
security cameras they got him on camera
they referred him for criminal
prosecution and the doj said yeah we're
not going to go after that
which honestly makes a lot of sense
this individual sure i mean nobody
should deface property
make sure i'm crystal clear on that
don't do it
but
it's always a but
um
you know writing on somebody's side like
writing bible verses putting stickers on
it is what they did um
you really want to criminally prosecute
somebody for that
i mean you're talking about
a misdemeanor offense
you know the value of which is far less
than anything that could even remotely
send somebody to jail
so you're mostly talking maybe giving
them probation maybe community service
maybe again we're talking about a very
minor misdemeanor probably just a fine
and marjorie taylor green is you know
basically crying every day because the
doj doesn't want to spend thousands of
dollars to prosecute somebody
for putting a couple stickers on her
sign
and of course she's mad about triumph
the insult comic dog colbert's staff you
know going in and
mocking her
and so she was given some time this week
on the floor of the house
which i don't know why she was given the
time but she was given the time and she
used it to paint herself as the biggest
victim
that the united states has ever seen
here it is take a look at marjorie
taylor green talking about how she is
being viciously attacked on all fronts
here it is i have come here as a
freshman member of congress and i want
to remind everyone i've never been
arrested i've always paid my taxes
i have not broken the law
i've done nothing wrong it's the
majority party that doesn't like my
speech that's it
so i've been kicked off committees i've
been routinely attacked
i have been lied about my character has
been completely destroyed not only by
people in here but the media definitely
helps them
now that was just a 32 second clip
of
representative green speaking on the
house floor about all these horrible
things she spoke for an hour
whining about how mistreated she has
been she spent more than 10 minutes of
that hour
talking about her poor little signs
and of course she claims that she was
attacked because the member of congress
across the hall put out a uh
you know lgbtq flag the idea was
actually the transgender flag
so that was an attack on her
so she had to fight back by putting her
little transphobic sign out there foe
she's just fighting back
i got no sympathy
for marjorie taylor green you have not
actually been attacked you've been
mocked you've been ridiculed sure but
you deserved every second of it
you want to talk about actual attacks
how about we talk about how you have
treated david hogg the parkland survivor
how you repeatedly harassed him
are you still to this day harass him on
twitter
luckily
that young man is far more mature than
marjorie taylor green could ever hope to
be how about before you even came into
office when you were essentially
stalking
aoc
are you yelling through her mail slot in
her office
there's been reports of you of course
walking down the hallway screaming at
democratic members of congress you know
we saw you the one time democrats doing
the press conference on the steps of the
capitol you came out and you started
screaming at them
those are attacks
and you have the audacity to sit there
on the floor of the house of
representatives
and whine about
a puppet
a puppet triumph insult comic dog is a
puppet
and you were triggered by the little
puppet it made you sad
and then of course your sign your poor
little sign oh you have to keep sending
your staffers over to fedex to make a
new sign oh dear me
how do you even get up in the morning
marjorie my
goodness maybe take yourself down off of
that cross for a minute
and look in a mirror
you want to know why people are are
horrible to you as you say
it's because you get back what you put
in
you have done nothing
to improve the lives of anyone in this
country
you have never shown anyone any kind of
basic niceties
you have been mean
you have been a bully
i mean heck you put out a video one time
you were in the middle of a workout you
stopped halfway through pulled out your
camera just to do a short video telling
joe biden he was a piece of you know
excrement
and then you went back to your workout
that's not even normal behavior like
that just goes beyond bullying to where
i would say that's almost a symptom in
my opinion
but you can't treat the entire world
like garbage
and then get mad when people dish it
back out to you
if you're gonna deliver it you better
learn how to take it
or better yet
maybe try being a decent human being for
a few minutes each day see how that
works out for you
but honestly
i don't think you have it in you